en 2004 après avoir parcouru un petit
peu les restaurants autour du monde et
avoir eu la chance de travailler pour
quelques très grands chefs
ma route m'a amené en belgique
mais suite à ça j'ai rencontré madame
martin et ils se faisaient que ses
parents avaient une institution à
bruxelles qui datent de 127 ans
maintenant et ses parents allaient en
fait cesser l'activité du mois ne savais
pas trop ce qu'ils allaient faire de
l'entreprise est alors que leur fille
rencontre un cuisinier forcément ça leur
a donné quand même quelques idées
et puis ça a été la négociation avec le
beau père alors je peux vous dire
qu'elle a beau père il est dur en
affaires et je lui dis voilà j'aimerais
venir travailler parce que je sentais le
potentiel de cette entreprise c'était
une institution
il y avait des clients qui était
fantastique c'était rempli tous les
jours c'était bien placé c'était un site
classé
donc si j'avais un jour le rêve d'ouvrir
un restaurant je crois que c'était un
petit peu dans dans cette location là et
donc la négociation fut fait avec mon
beau père qui me coupe pas mon ancien
salaire par quatre c'était la première
mauvaise nouvelle est la deuxième
nouvelle c'était de me dire qui reprend
le restaurant mais il va falloir
continuer parce que c'est une
institution
ça fonctionne comme ça depuis 35 ans
quand est ce que l'on exploite
l'établissement et c'est pour ça que ça
marche
bon mais voilà descendu dans cette
cuisine en sous sol moi qui avais eu la
chance de travailler par miley des plus
belles cuisines sur cette belle planète
avec l'air conditionné vue sur la mer
vue sur la montagne enfin bon je me
retrouve dans une cave anderlech bon
pourquoi pas et puis
je me rappelle la première semaine
j'avais un marteau et un burin puis je
tapais sur les murs donc les murs faut
savoir que cette cuisine c'est la raison
pour laquelle n'y a pas de slide
aujourd'hui c'est que je peux pas vous
la montrer du moins comme elle l'était
avant je vous invite à aller la visiter
mais comme elle était avant c'est pas
possible
les plâtres à tomber il y avait au moins
deux centimètres de couches de peinture
il y avait certaines parties de la
cuisine qui était impossible à nettoyer
donc là pour moi c'était un petit peu le
début du cauchemar
mais au-delà de ça ce restaurant avait
une âme il fonctionnait mais il
fonctionnait tenu à bout de bras par mes
beaux parents qui sont d'aider des
restaurateurs n'est qu'ils sont des
personnes extraordinaires sans se rendre
compte que même qu'en fait il le tenait
à bout de bras
simplement par sympathie de la part des
clients quand je revois encore des
clients aujourd'hui qui me disent tu
sais c'était pas bon les dernières
années mais quand même tes beaux parents
ce sont des gens formidables et donc on
se rendait compte que les gens venaient
simplement parce que mon beau père à la
fin du repas quand il passait aux tables
que le client ne s'étaient pas très bon
ces emprunts cigares et un petit pousse
café tu verras ça ira mieux et donc ça
finissait à 8 heures le soir en train de
boire du pousse café quand les clients
partent et finalement c'était le
meilleur restaurant de belgique
et puis on a voulu moderniser un petit
on a voulu on avait j'avais travaillé un
petit peu partout et la chance d'avoir
cette expérience je me suis dit
maintenant il est temps il est temps de
relancer les temps de faire la version
2.0 de la paix puis de relancer pour le
futur d'assurer la pérennité de
l'entreprise
impossible toute tentative était avortée
par les clients mon premier et mon beau
père qui était devenu client et le piège
s'était refermé
alors si on devait mesurer le bonheur au
chiffre d'affaires et aux résultats
d'entreprises
ça aurait dû être le chef le plus
heureux de belgique
malheureusement ce n'était pas suffisant
ce n'était pas suffisant parce que il y
avait cette énergie et cette énergie ont
souhaité la transformer en créativité et
cette créativité l'offrir et la partager
avec les clients donc le piège s'étant
refermée
j'ai décidé de partir de m'isoler et
j'étais fan depuis longtemps du japon
tout cas de cette cuisine de l'esprit
qui va avec mais j' étais jamais allé et
j'ai décidé je suis parti je suis parti
pendant quinze jours en quinze jours
j'ai mangé dans 40 restaurants parmi les
plus grands restaurants qui a au japon
et ça a été le choc
je savais que j'allais être perturbée en
partant mais le choc était énorme et je
me souviens avoir discuté d'abord avec
une famille qui faisait depuis une
entreprise qui était familiale depuis
plus de 500 ans parce qu'il faut savoir
que japon quand on parle d'entreprises
familiales on passe les cinq ou six
siècles ces gens fabriquent et du soja
alors le soja ça parle peut être un
petit peu à tout le monde
c'est un petit peu la définition de la
cuisine asiatique aujourd'hui pour faire
un poulet la japonaise mais un petit peu
de gens c'est du poulet la japonaise
pour faire des crevettes à la japonaise
ou enfin est il fabriqué mille litres de
soja par an et connaissant quelques
grands chefs à travers le monde il y
avait une liste d'attenté et je demande
à la personne du moins aux traducteurs
pourquoi est ce qu'ils produisent pas
dix mille litres
parce qu'ils les vendrais et la personne
me répond on ne produira jamais dix
mille litres
on continuera à produire 1000 litres
mais chaque année de mieux en mieux bon
et ça c'était un petit peu la
déformation qu'on avait quand on est un
restaurant avec 50 places
on espère que dans trois ans il est 100
places dans quatre ans il 150 places et
finalement c'était pas la solution est
de retour
à bruxelles le choc a été grand on a
fermé le restaurant pendant quelques
jours le temps de faire le point
on a fait table rase fait venir les
architectes
on a commencé très rapidement les
travaux on a réouvert la cuisine était
en gros on a coupé la salle le volume de
la salle par 4 est passé de 125 places à
30 places et on a enfin sorti la carte
qu'on aurait dû sortir depuis longtemps
alors la première rébellion ça a été la
mienne ça a été celle des clients les
clients fuient avec le chiffre
d'affaires ça c'était un petit peu moins
amusant mais finalement les mois passant
le résultat de l'entreprise à la fin de
l'année et est quand même positif
donc ça a été le deuxième signe qui a
fait que l'on a continué à se développer
et ce développement est le fait de
lâcher cette créativité a fait qu'on a
ouvert un deuxième établissement
et puis on a lancé avec le producteur
dominique leroy une émission de cuisine
nous sommes à la 700ème émissions
maintenant on a lancé des sociétés de
consulting tous est ouvert tous et
ouvert simplement parce qu'on a refusé
de finir et gris refusé de passer devant
un établissement qui était à remettre et
on sentait que le potentiel était aussi
grand que celui de la paix en se disant
je veux pas y repasser devant dans dix
ans il me dira si j'avais su donc si
j'avais su ce n'est pas tout à fait dans
mon tempérament
mais voilà ça ça a été le nôtre
rebellyon à nous c'est à dire d'aller
jusqu'au bout des choses d'aller
jusqu'au bout de ses idées quitte à
prendre le risque
mais je pense que quand on est persuadé
il pas de raison que l'on échoue et
j'aimerais une chose aujourd'hui c'est
que si dans la salle il y en a même s'il
y en a un qui a envie d'aller au bout de
ses rêves ou qui a envie de réaliser ce
qu'il souhaite qu'il le fasse parce
qu'au bout finalement c'est le bonheur
merci